foreign
[Music]
have a chat
I'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me it's smiling at me
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
[Music]
I need to find an explanation for what
happened oh
smiling at me
smiling at me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
I found 20 cases involving 19 victims
with a direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it just dead in your life
seen it too
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day I am not gonna
keep running
face it how does that make you feel
[Music]
thank you
I'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
oh
yeah
[Music]
no one knows how it starts
but when the fear begins
when the paranoia takes over
it makes people do terrible things
good morning as you can see some of you
have chosen to stay home today given
what's been happening
there's something going around some
scary internet character that tells you
to kill people it made this kid stab his
own mother there's a lot of people
freaking out about it nobody knows what
it actually is
laughs
you saw the Grim Cutty yeah like in my
house what is it
[Music]
we've been getting calls about it all
night
how are we supposed to protect our
family
my parents can't see it but when I try
to tell them what I saw just makes it
more hysterical
foreign
can we start over
we can just sit down and I'll talk it
out together
I'm just trying to protect him
is that going to fit everyone easily 12
customers total how do they turn a
profit 12.50 ahead that's how what are
we eating a Rolex
one of his classics
you have to try the mouse feel with the
minionette please don't say a mouthful
tonight will be Madness
welcome
we'll Endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to Hawthorne
Here We are family
we Harvest we ferment we gel
great gel we gel
he's not just a chef he's a storyteller
he's trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
going to be
you won't know until the end
who are you I am Marco
how do you care I have to know if you're
with us or with them
this menu the pictures they're of us
this guest list how do they get these
it's not good this entire evening
Jesus Christ this is just theater it's
stage crowd we're leaving now has been
painstakingly planned
this is really heavy what the hell is
going on
we now offer you a 45 second Head Start
okay 45 seconds Starts Now
this is what you're paying for
get out of their way
it's all part of the menu
[Music]
you told him it was my birthday seemed
funny about three hours ago
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why are you here I suppose I'm here to
make friends with you
your Dad's too
but my heart is broken why is it broken
because of what I have to do today
[Music]
you see the four of us have a very
important job to do
in fact it might be the most important
job
history of the world
all right
we were called
and are united by a common vision
which has now become a command
that we cannot ignore
[Music]
the four of us are here
to prevent the Apocalypse
your family hasn't chosen to make a
horrible decision
a world went
foreign
[Music]
get me [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful isn't it
it's really nice
you can hold it
what is it
it's a puzzle
[Applause]
and it's almost finished
keep going
so if I solve it
do I get a prize
I do
[Music]
What's your deal it has six sides six
configurations
it opens up
Cuts you it
[Applause]
and then they come to collect
laughs
it's time
greater Delights await we wish to see
you proceed
their blood
their pain
all for us
that you pray for
these sessions are mandatory for all
staff Sister Anne
my mother struggled with depression
Annie Annie can I come in
here
my mother talked about hearing that
voice inside
she said the voice didn't really want
her
it wanted me
Citadel Has Fallen
South the sun because as some of you may
already know we have a female student in
the class only as an observer so let's
descend into the mouth of Hell shall we
there are more possessions reported
today than at any other time in history
sir we must fight for every soul
[Music]
defend Us in battle against the spirits
of wickedness
[Music]
I believe the demon that is tormenting
Natalie and the demon that possessed my
mother are one in the same
I like to teach Sister Act just enough
to protect herself and others
this relationship she had
it's personal
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
your mother has a pretty voice
be careful once you know the demo
the devil's next year
foreign
[Music]
are you okay
[Music]
I had an overdose
come home I could look after you
everything here is just like old times
you're the first person I've seen who
actually looks like they've got any
older since I left
doesn't anyone die around here
I knew I recognized you
your mother she's very popular in the
village
[Music]
[Applause]
Mom oh I've missed that word
say it again
this isn't how I remember it things
change you haven't I never hurt you
remember when you threatened to take my
mouth shut
I want to try to get past the past of
course
[Music]
your mum asked me to make sure you
didn't leave do something out there
something against God
something
changed your mother and change the
village
[Music]
what's happening to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't believe you're moving this
summer we're always gonna be friends
pick you up in time
[Music]
it's gonna be hot this weekend should we
do something
[Music]
[Music]
it's over there this weird little
building where that girl was sacrificed
in a Satanic ritual let's go in come on
ABS one more Adventure
[Music]
[Music]
where were you where were you
your friend if you get sick physically
she's got a grotesque and gnarly
well then she got better right she looks
copacetic but up here in cuckoo for
Cocoa Pops I guess that's one way to put
it dollars of donuts it's demonic
possession
she needs an exorcism
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what was that
[Music]
damn we got ourselves a demon
[Music]
I Think We're Alone Now
oh my God
it doesn't seem to be anyone around
girls believe in Paranormal Activity
Spirits a demonologist
no I don't well I do because I'm gonna
be playing one
they want you back in for a call back on
Monday yes
I need this roll
I saw your ad
[Music]
Vice
I need you to trust me there can be no
lies or the ritual will have very little
chance of success
ritual
[Laughter]
an exorcism
it's a human blood shall we get started
David's coming in any forms
I need to be great or else they're gonna
give the role to Donald
Trump told me you already had this
problem
that
was a lie
you're scared I am not scared
are you out of your mind
what are you hiding from
how do I get out of here you don't
I've been waiting for you my whole mind
[Music]
this place is great
can fix it up this is what we wanted
welcome home
this is Robert my husband it is so nice
to meet you Robert
yeah I guess I can see your resemblance
it looks like me
Robert I know you're new to these parts
[Music]
for everyone when I say you already feel
like one of us
[Music]
that's not for sale I was just hoping
you might be able to give me some more
information about it
you want answers you're wrong
you know I just found another painting
of him
I feel like everyone knows okay listen
you don't actually think that's you
[Music]
something is off
about this place
I swear it's the same guy in every
single one I would just take it as a
sign
you are where you are meant to be
neat do you understand me no go go
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Halloween you can't escape the
shark the terror of
werewolf by night tonight it is every
Hunter for themselves good luck I'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Music]
starting
please don't do this
death is coming for you
werewolf by night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow I wonder he lives here
we're sure this Jeff's empty
finger hello
oh what's going on
last night you made the unfortunate
mistake of breaking into my ancestral
home
don't worry this is not an execution
where's the sport in that good luck
why did you let us go why did they wish
us luck
what's that
it's a fox hunt
oh yeah
foreign
people are gonna find out about this
about what
I
miss you
[Music]
love mommy
say bye-bye hi Mommy
[Music]
hi she's here I don't want you to feel
overwhelmed okay here's any number you
need including her therapist thank you
let's go
upstairs from the sky just work hard to
keep it where you from stats we've been
asked South Africa okay Senegal oh we
got a winner
[Music]
I haven't seen my son been almost there
yet your son yes I need to bring him
here
very soon
do not ignore the science
you have your pain me but I am odd you
think Ash is just laying around I
thought so
[Music]
I miss my country
every day
you're gonna be okay
I wish I knew what's happening to me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
against him
his friend
and
and we'll play a new game
okay mum chaos
and pain
[Music]
Allison she's alive
she's back
increment and initialize
I believe this task within the allotted
time if the task is not completed with
an acceptable parameters your daughter
will die
task complete
[Music]
are there
Eileen
get up save Roger my husband
what did you do to me
why are you doing this
there's my daughter
[Music]
foreign
calm down
[Music]